arm feels really really good we threw a
lot of balls yesterday
and um you know kind of waking up today
to see
how it was going to feel and it feels
great and that's kind of what i
anticipated because
we've been working more than usual in
offseason
in terms of growing um i've
put together really a regimen of two to
three days a week
of throwing for the last probably kind
of two months
if not longer than that too so
i think the plan is still to kind of um
really kind of pitch count if you will
through training camp obviously this is
a little different training camp because
you're not really doing one-on-ones and
you're not doing seven on seven right
now so
right now we're just building up and
work on timing with receivers tight ends
running backs things like that so
i have had no setbacks it feels it feels
really really good and so i'm really
excited about that
ben roethlisberger talking to reporters
for the first time this season
had that elbow surgery last year that
knocked him out of 15 games actually 14
plus games the steelers were thrown into
disarray and they still almost made it
to the playoffs with
mason rudolph and doc hodges at
quarterback chris you
talked to roethlisberger last year
training camp
and he said he basically doesn't do
anything in the offseason well now he's
starting to realize he's got to put in
the work if he wants to extend the
career
he looks leaner he looks more fit i've
seen pictures of him on twitter where he
looks like a different
guy right uh and and he said yesterday
he's still in it to win lombardi's
with an s he's got two on his resume
it's been a long time since the last one
it's now 12 years since
the second super bowl victory 10 years
since the last
super bowl appearance by the steelers
when they lost to the packers and aaron
rodgers
uh and hey look i i'm never going to
count out the steelers
especially when you count them out is
when they rise up and bite you in the
butt and go to the super bowl and
potentially win it
this team is dangerous mike tomlin is
one of the best coaches in the nfl
if roethlisberger is healthy and they
can get some production in the running
game
and get someone to stretch the field
offensively yeah that that defense has
gotten so much
better quiet that's the reason why that
team had a chance last year it wasn't
the offense
it was the defense if that offense can
get back to what it was just a few years
ago at a time when the defense
is much better than it had been in years
this is a team that can be very
dangerous
i i agree mike i i think there are one
of those teams that you know
we might not put in that main
conversation for super bowl
with some of the elite teams but like
you know yeah sitting here right now
august whatever the hell day it is sixth
or whatever five
five early august five and would i be si
would i wouldn't be shocked if it came
february and the pittsburgh steelers
were in the super bowl the defense is a
super bowl defense as you just mentioned
you know and they were you know very
good last year
with absolutely no offense and just
really below average quarterback play in
a lot of games
so to have big bend back and to hear
that he's been throwing and everything
i've seen i
it it looks good mike it sounds good
coming out of there too
all the things you hear out of
pittsburgh so that is exciting but i
think you hit it mike
you know running game yeah can we get a
running game this year you know they
drafted the kid
mcfarland out of maryland to go with
james connor can he help out he's like
he's got a rocket up his butt maybe two
of them mike you know and then
yeah who is that receiver that's gonna
jump up we saw james washington take a
step in the right direction last year
uh deontay johnson he's a guy they
drafted in
you know in the mid rounds two uh two
drafts ago they need him to step
up chase claypool who's it gonna be but
uh i i'm with you mike you know
they need that other guy along with juju
to take pressure off juju so we can see
what juju is all about again once again
too because
you know i think one thing we saw last
year is he's not a
like prime time number one game-changing
type receiver he needs somebody across
from him to help him out a little bit i
do think that's the case
uh but i'm excited about the steelers
this is the keenan allen argument that
we had recently not that we had an
argument because we both agreed he had
an argument with where he was placed on
some top 10 lists
if you can't stretch the field and
command double coverage you're not
a top end receiver and i remember last
year
i don't know that it was right around
this time but it was some point in that
golf between
may and august where juju came out and
said how much he's working
on getting open deep
the guys who are the best at it don't
work at it no you just go
do it right right and that was the first
flag for me that this is
just because the guy was the team mvp in
2018 and that lit the fuse on antonio
brown finally wanting out
you know that's why antonio brown was
upset he knows that juju got all those
opportunities all those catches because
he had the number one that was taking
all the attention
juju can't be the number one he could be
a great great great great great number
two
but they need someone to be the number
one and uh that's one of the unknowns
this year and
you know that that's that that's why you
put antonio brown
on your list of teams the other day the
steelers on the list of teams that
should go get antonio brown because that
would
instantly give them back the number one
that they didn't have yeah
exactly right you know yeah for right
now you're you're gonna have to prove on
unpre you know you're gonna have to rely
on unproven commodities
that's that's the big thing and you know
not that the other guy needs to be a
number one or be antonio brown
you can be a really good offense and
have all number two type receivers you
know
or or a bunch of number threes and just
a one real good number two
and maybe that's the case or they have
to find the role or whatever it may be
for certain guys here but
you know that that is the big thing the
run game gave them nothing
last year you know the offensive line is
getting up there in age they're not
quite as dominant as they were
you know maybe four or five years ago
but you know they got to get more out of
james connor
they need more you know something out of
this rookie anthony mcfarlane
and then if big ben stays healthy you
know i think he's going to get this wide
receiver group
going he'll get them confidence it's
hard when you're a young guy and you got
a quarterback you know that can't really
deliver the ball consistently is all
over the place
for you to grow as a receiver when
you're not getting the right
opportunities either so
you know i'm hopeful that they'll take
the right steps and as we talk about a
lot
they're a team that always seems to know
receivers and you know i love that chase
claypool at a notre dame and i would
wouldn't be shocked he would be one of
my under the radar rookie of the year
candidates
that i would throw out there to some
people if they want to lay down some
change right now
and here's the caveat that we need to
attach here at least i do you may
agree with me chris you may not if you
agree with me great if you don't i don't
care
i just because you know if ben
rothersberger had this elbow thing when
he was 25
then okay we got it fixed we did what we
had to do he's rehabbed he's good to go
he's good to go for another 10 years
i think back to the photos of him
whether it was this camp
last year or the one before that where
he looks like the stay puft marshmallow
man
with the ice pack on his shoulder and an
ice pack on this elbow and ice pack
that was me at training camp last year
with him okay all these ice packs right
what is the elbow the first
of just the system breakdown here's a
guy who has played for years
who's always carried around more weight
than he should banging on his joints and
his bones and his cartilage and his
ligaments
and getting hit a lot getting injured
from time to time
is the elbow the first thing to go and
will it just be a matter of
what's next that if i'm a steelers fan
that's the thing that has me awake at
night worrying that it's
back to the mason rudolph and doc hodges
show because they didn't go out and
upgrade the backup
quarterback position what do you think
of that well no i
i i think it's something i'll be looking
forward to
i don't expect that to be the case i
don't
you know uh but i mean your point is
very real
he took a beating he played the position
about as physical as you could play it
for a period of time
and i don't know if he quite gets the
respect for that you're right that would
be what i'm scared a little bit too is
that just has
all of it caught up to him and yeah
you're right this is the first of
many other issues but i'm hoping that's
not the case and the big thing is with
the elbow and i saw it at training camp
last year
and hopefully he's learned from it yeah
there's the picture you know yeah he
hadn't been throwing all off season he
told me he threw a few passes to his
kids that's all it was
and you know then all of a sudden you
get into training camp and you start
throwing the ball hard and the number of
balls you throw per day
it wears you out to where he got
tendinitis and obviously caused some
damage in there to
to the ligament so uh i'm hoping it's
just that but
yeah mike that concern's real there's no
doubt
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports